>> Bret: WELCOME BACK WITH
FORMER FBI DIRECTOR JAMES
COMEY.
SINCE YOUR FIRING, HAVE YOU
MET WITH FORMER CIA DIRECTOR
JOHN BRENNAN?
>> YES.
ONCE, I THINK.
>> Bret: AND FORMER NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE DIRECTOR JIM
CLAPPER?
>> YEAH.
I SAW HIM THE NIGHT BEFORE
LAST.
>> Bret: TOGETHER.
>> ACTUALLY I HAD DINNER
WITH THE TWO OF THEM AND OUR
SPOUSES.
>> Bret: TALK TRUMP CASE.
>> NO, WE DID NOT.
>> Bret: AFTER YOUR
HAND-PICKED DEPUTY ANDY
MCCABE WAS FIRED, YOU
TWEETED THIS, YOU SAID
SPECIAL AGENT MCCABE STOOD
TALL OVER THE LAST 8 MONTHS
WHEN SMALL PEOPLE WERE
TRYING TO TEAR DOWN AN
INSTITUTION WE ALL DEPEND
ON.
HE SERVED WITH DISTINCTION
FOR TWO DECADES I WISH ANDY
WELL.
I WISH CONTINUED STRENGTH
FOR THE REST OF THE FBI.
AMERICA NEEDS YOU.
YOU KNOW THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL FOUND THAT MCCABE
LIED FOUR TIMES, THREE OF
THEM UNDER OATH.
KIMBERLY STROSSEL FROM THE
"WALL STREET JOURNAL" TWEET
ADD LOT OF POSSIBLE
QUESTIONS FOR YOU BUT HERE'S
ONE.
PLEASE DISCUSS ANDREW MCCABE
AND THE IG REPORT THAT FINDS
HE LIED REPEATEDLY, BOTH TO
YOU AND ABOUT YOU.
DO YOU STILL BELIEVE HE
STOOD TALL AS YOU TWEETED IN
JANUARY OR IS HE ONE OF THE
SMALL PEOPLE HELPING TO TEAR
DOWN AN INSTITUTION?
>> YEAH.
I STILL BELIEVE HE STOOD
TALL.
HE REPRESENTED HIMSELF AND
THE ORGANIZATION UNDER
TREMENDOUS STRESS DURING
THAT PERIOD AFTER I WAS
FIRED.
BUT I READ THE IG REPORT AS
YOU DID.
IT CONCLUDED THAT ANDY HAD
NOT BEEN CANDID.
THIS IS WHAT ACCOUNTABILITY
LOOKS LIKE IN THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
>> Bret: SHOULD HE BE
PROSECUTED?
>> THAT'S NOT FOR ME.
>> Bret: YOU SAID IT IN THE
CLINTON CASE.
>> I WAS THEN THE DIRECTOR
OF THE FBI.
I'M A PRIVATE CITIZEN.
PRIVATE CITIZENS SHOULD NOT
BE CALLING FOR THE
PROSECUTION OF PEOPLE IN A
CASE THEY ARE NOT INVOLVED
IN.
BUT, I DO BELIEVE, AS IT
ROUTINELY HAPPENS, THE IG
WILL LIKELY REFER OR HAS
REFERRED IT TO A U.S.
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE TO LOOK AT
IT.
>> Bret: SO, DID YOU -- YOU
SEE THE DISPARITY HERE WHERE
PEOPLE LOOK AT HOW THE
CLINTON CASE WAS HANDLED AND
HOW THE TRUMP CASE IS
HANDLED.
DID YOU TELL --
>> -- I DON'T SEE DISPARITY
THOUGH.
>> Bret: DID YOU TELL
LAWMAKERS THAT FBI AGENTS
DIDN'T BELIEVE FORMER
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR
MICHAEL FLYNN WAS LYING
INTENTIONALLY TO
INVESTIGATORS?
>> NO.
AND I SAW THAT IN THE MEDIA.
MAYBE SOMEONE MISUNDERSTOOD
SOMETHING I SAID.
I DIDN'T BELIEVE THAT AND
DIDIDN'T SAY THAT.
>> Bret: ABOUT THE
CONTROVERSIAL TEXT MESSAGES,
WE JUST RECEIVED A LOT MORE
UP ON CAPITOL HILL TODAY.
IF YOU KNEW BACK THEN WHEN
YOU WERE IN CHARGE OF THE
INVESTIGATION, AND YOU SAW
THOSE TEXTS BETWEEN PETER
STRZOK AND LISA PAGE, THE
LEVEL OF ANIMUS THEY HAD
AGAINST PRESIDENT TRUMP,
WHAT WOULD HAVE YOU DONE.
>> I WOULD HAVE REMOVED BOTH
OF THEM FROM ANY CONTACT
WITH SIGNIFICANT
INVESTIGATIONS.
>> Bret: SO SHOULDN'T THEIR
WORK --
>> -- INCLUDING THOSE
INVOLVING ANYBODY CONNECTED
TO PRESIDENT TRUMP BUT
BEYOND THAT SUCH POOR
JUDGMENT.
>> Bret: SHOULD THEIR WORK
PRODUCT THEN BE QUESTIONED.
>> SURE.
IT'S A REASONABLE QUESTION
TO ASK.
THEY WERE BAD MOUTHING
EVERYBODY, INCLUDING
CANDIDATE TRUMP.
>> Bret: PETER STRZOK
INTERVIEWS HILLARY CLINTON.
DEALS WITH THE BLEACH BIT
AND THE SERVER AND CHERYL
MILLS, ALL OF THAT
INTERVIEWS MICHAEL FLYNN,
AND INTEGRAL IN THIS WHOLE
CASE.
>> HE IS ONE OF MANY OTHER
PEOPLE INVOLVED IN ALL THE
THINGS YOU JUST TICKED OFF.
IT'S A REASONABLE QUESTION
TO ASK.
AND I CAN TELL YOU THIS.
WHEN I SAW THE TEXT, I WAS
DEEPLY DISAPPOINTED IN THEM.
BUT I NEVER SAW ANY BIAS ANY
REFLECTION OF ANY KIND OF
ANIMUS TOWARDS ANYBODY.
INCLUDING ME.
THOSE TEXTS.
I'M NOT GOING TO READ THEM
ALL.
NEVER SAW IT THAT'S WHY WE
HAVE SUCH A BIG.
>> Bret: THE BUCK STOPS WITH
YOU.
>> OF COURSE.
>> Bret: JONATHAN TWEETED IN
WHAT WAS THE INSURANCE
POLICY DEPUTY DIRECTOR
MCCABE STRZOK AND PAGE WERE
DISGUSTING IN HIS OFFICE.
>> I DON'T HAVE ANY IDEA.
>> Bret: NO CLUE.
>> IF ANYBODY PULLED ANY OF
YOUR LISTENERS TEXT OR
VIEWERS' TEXTS NO CONTEXT
HARD TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT.
>> Bret: THERE IS A LOST OF
TEXT AND A LOT OF CONTEXT
WITH THOSE GUYS.
>> THE ONES I HAVE LOOKED AT
I HAVE HAD A HARD TIME
FIGURING OUT.
>> Bret: THIS MORNING THE
PRESIDENT ALSO SAID THIS ON
"FOX & FRIENDS."
>> IF YOU LOOK AT THE
CORRUPTION AT THE TOP OF THE
FBI, IT'S A DISGRACE.
AND OUR JUSTICE DEPARTMENT,
WHICH I TRY AND STAY AWAY
FROM, BUT AT SOME POINT I
WON'T.
>> Bret: WHAT DO YOU THINK
HE MEANT THERE?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I HOPE HE DIDN'T MEAN THAT
HE IS GOING TO DECIDE BY
EXECUTIVE FIAT TO DIRECT THE
ACTIONS OF WHAT IS SUPPOSED
TO BE AN IMPARTIAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT FUNCTION.
LADY JUSTICE HAS A
BLINDFOLD.
IT SHOULD STAY ON.
>> Bret: DID THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL INTERVIEW YOU ABOUT
YOUR HANDLING OF THE MEMOS?
>> SURE, YEAH.
>> Bret: HAS?
>> HAS ALREADY.
I EXPECT A REPORT ON THEM
NOT ON THE HANDLING OF
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION
BECAUSE THAT'S FRIVOLOUS BUT
ON DID I COMPLY WITH POLICY?
DID I COMPLY WITH MY
EMPLOYMENT AGREEMENT?
>> Bret: YOU SAID YOU DIDN'T
LEAK THERE IS A "NEW YORK
TIMES" STORY IN APRIL 2017
THAT FIRST REPORTED THE
LORETTA LYNCH EMAIL.
YOU DIDN'T WRITE IT B. IT
HERE IN THIS BOOK BECAUSE
YOU SAID IT'S CLASSIFIED.
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" WROTE A
LOT ABOUT IT DID THE FBI
PUBLIC AFFAIRS COORDINATE
THAT STORY.
>> NOT TO MY KNOWLEDGE.
I'M NOT GOING TO COMMENT ON
ANY STORIES BECAUSE I'M NOT
ALLOWED TO CONFIRM OR DENY
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
>> Bret: ALL RIGHT IN THE
INFAMOUS OVAL OFFICE MEETING
WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP WHEN HE
ASKED YOU TO STAY BEHIND
ONE-ON-ONE.
YOU WRITE IN THE BOOK THAT
YOU FELT AWKWARD.
YOU DIDN'T LIKE IT.
>> CORRECT.
>> Bret: YOU HAD BEEN
ONE-ON-ONE WITH PRESIDENT
OBAMA IN THE OVAL OFFICE?
>> CORRECT.
>> Bret: BUT THIS WAS
DIFFERENT.
>> YEAH.
BECAUSE HE BOOTED OUT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
UNITED STATES WHO WAS
LINGERING TRYING TO STAY.
>> Bret: AS OPPOSED TO THE
PRESIDENTIAL PHOTOGRAPHER
WHO PRESIDENT OBAMA BOOTS
OUT?
>> SURE.
>> Bret: YOU SAY YOU DIDN'T
PUSH BACK WHEN HE SAID HE
HOPED YOU COULD SEE YOUR WAY
THAT HE WAS A GOOD GUY.
HOPED YOU COULD LET IT GO.
YOU SAY YOU DIDN'T PUSH BACK
AND HE SHOULD HAVE KNOWN
THAT HE COULDN'T DO THAT.
ALL RIGHT.
SO LET'S ASSUME THAT'S TRUE
THAT HE SHOULD HAVE KNOWN.
THAT IS IT POSSIBLE THERE
WAS ANOTHER REASON WHY YOU
DIDN'T PUSH BACK AND THAT IS
THAT YOU WANTED TO KEEP YOUR
JOB?
>> IT'S POSSIBLE BUT IT'S
NOT THE CASE.
AT LEAST I DON'T REMEMBER
THINKING ABOUT THAT AT THE
TIME.
>> Bret: YOU TOLD CNN LAST
NIGHT THAT YOU DIDN'T THINK
YOU WOULD BE FIRED.
THAT YOU KNOW, HAD YOU NOT
BEEN FIRED, YOU WOULD STILL
BE WORKING AS FBI DIRECTOR
TONIGHT.
>> YEAH.
IN FACT, THAT WAS MY
INTENTION TO SERVE ANOTHER
SIX YEARS.
>> Bret: SO, DESPITE THE
FACT THAT NOW YOU SAY THAT
THIS PRESIDENT IS MORALLY
UNFIT, THAT YOU SAY
IMPEACHMENT IS TOO GOOD OF A
REMEDY ON THE BOOK TOUR.
>> THAT'S NOT WHAT I SAID.
I SAID IN A WAY I HOPE NOT
BECAUSE I THINK THE VOTERS
NEED TO SPEAK.
BRET BRET EXACTLY ON THE
MEDIA TOUR AND THE BLITZ YOU
ARE BASICALLY ENCOURAGING
VOTERS TO VOTE TRUMP OUT OF
OFFICE BECAUSE HE DOESN'T
LINE UP WITH YOUR VALUES.
>> I'M ASKING THEM TO VOTE
THEIR VALUES AND WHAT I
BELIEVE YOUR VIEWERS WOULD
AGREE ARE AMERICA'S VALUES.
>> Bret: OKAY.
BUT AS OF TONIGHT, HAD YOU
NOT BEEN FIRED, YOU WOULD
STILL BE WORKING FOR THIS
GUY THAT YOU SAY IS LIKE A
CRIME BOSS WHO IS MORALLY
UNFIT, WHO YOU JUST DON'T
AGREE WITH ON PRINCIPLE AND
VALUES.
YOU WOULD STILL HAVE THAT
JOB TONIGHT?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AND MY GOAL WOULD TO BE
PROTECT THE FBI AND SERVE
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
>> Bret: WHEN YOU SAY.
>> I RESPECT THAT OFFICE
TREMENDOUSLY.
>> Bret: WHEN YOU SAY TO
REPUBLICANS WHY DO YOU WORK
WITH THIS PRESIDENT AND SIT